ارجوحه محللين وعسكريين بطول امه هذه
الحرب وسيناريوهاتها المتوقعه نتابع هذه
السيناريوهات ونعود للنقاش
اذا كما شاهدنا مشاهدينا في حرب اوكرانيا
منذ بدايه عام 2023 الايام الاولى من
العام الجديد تنبئ باستمرار المعارك على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه فكل طرف يواصل تجهيز
قوته العسكريه على طريقته فبينما تعزز
موسكو صفوفها بقوات اضافيه لا يزال الجيش
الاوكراني يراهن بشكل كبير على الاسلحه
الغربيه في هذا السياق اعتبرت صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه ان الاسلحه
الجديده التي وعدت بها اوكرانيا تعد مؤشرا
واضحا على ان المواجهات مستمره لفتره ليست
بالقصير
وصحيفه خابت اكثر في الخطوه التي اتخذها
الحلفاء الغربيون بتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
النوعيه وما يحمله ذلك من دلالات فصحيفه
ورات في ذلك تاكيدا على تخطيط الحلفاء
الغربيين لاوكرانيا الى دعم الهجمات
الاوكرانيه وفضل الهجمات الروسيه كما ان
هذا الدعم يوحي الى رغبه كل من الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا والمانيا في تقديم دعم
اكثر فتكا للاوكرانيين هذا فضلا على ان
هذه الخطوه
تحمل او تلمح الى عدم رغبه المعسكر الغربي
في الدخول في مفاوضات سلام مع روسيا على
المدى القريب على الاقل وهو ما يفتح الحرب
على سيناريوهات